[Music]
and cocktail captain news captain new
Coker submitted by David's armpit Heil
price smells good like cream cheese it
doesn't have her you plucked it off
Vanessa wanted to use wax on it the
other day yeah and so I let her and it
is by far one of the worst experiences
I've ever had in my life
we got ours wax she's just like he did
we can't use Lance on it well she was
gonna wax hers and say she was like hey
I'm with you like in there like she just
goes to your house to go over some wack
scene and then she was gonna wax her
[ __ ] she's like I want to do yours I was
like okay well let's just record it then
and I in my mind I knew I was gonna be
painful I didn't realize how painful
it's close to crime yeah I [ __ ] bled
dude oh yeah we bled too is not about
man I was judging you not stop until you
said video and then of my oh yeah well
if you do it context earlier yeah I was
like if we're gonna do it then we're
gonna have to record it and then I was
like I can handle this type of pain hmm
I couldn't do the other one it does hurt
but we also had a professional oh we had
a ghetto one so it didn't rip any of it
just pulled on him oh and if she did it
again pulled on it again and blood I was
like done I'm done with this I can't do
this ours was clean it was like BAM I
just clean but we still blend a luxury
yacht owner and his captain have been
charged in a horrific coke-fueled death
he used coke acidic gasoline
uh very so was the captain and so the
captain was just really coked out they
had people on the yacht and at one point
the coked out captain put the guy in
reverse and shredded a person oh and
they would injure the propellers yeah
holy [ __ ] dude that's like my worst
night were they allowed to swim outside
of the boat yeah sometimes they Park it
and then people jump off and play around
the boat dude that's like us well we
went into the yacht and we jumped off
and yeah listen the captain turns it on
and we get sliced up yeah wait that
happened to you know if no no we were in
we went on a yacht though and they know
we were it was a catamaran
so it was fun because you could swim
under it and then we were like grabbing
the net under and I didn't like it was
one that's really cool like the same one
that we all went on are you guys
drenched no it was another one in when
we went on a Hawaii trip there was a
catamaran - right
oh yeah it's like that yeah yeah but
that Academy right after the NARS yeah
so this one here is though I am
it's a 90-foot yacht called Miami Vice
something on one so like there's people
that got called Miami Vice and they do
coke and they're surprised right captain
is a coke head that's funny
and the owner knew that he was a coke
head too because they three days before
this happened to this 25 year old me
Raul died
the owner was filming the captain do
some coke doing coke and he said in
French the captain takes his vitamin so
the owner is a French man and and he's a
coke head - well I don't know if you if
he condones it I have a buddy who had
his girlfriend at the time um he had
never turned coke before but he wanted
to try it just so he could say he did
coke but he also wanted to do a specific
sexual act with her so that he could say
that he did it it took him a couple
tries but he put a bunch of like a line
of coke on his dick like so he got his
dick hard and then he put a line of coke
on his dick and then his girlfriend
snorted the coke off his dick so he
didn't take coke at all no he did coke
already but then he had her take coke
off of his desk pretty tight sight
that's extreme for his first experience
he wanted to have the story just for the
story he could have lied no that's how
he is very neurotic so he was like he
wanted to be able to say like that his
girlfriend did snorting coke on Thursday
he's never done it ever before that's
pretty cool yeah that's cool I think
it's cool it's fun I think you wouldn't
do a lot of coke off the birthday I
would do anything off of Bart's dicks
but I'm just saying I don't think it's
cool I'm not gonna be like oh I did coke
off my man's dick well not if you say
like that I think that the Sonor it's
outside of the norm of your normal train
of thought it's like once at the height
of pimp oh right there's no but higher
height right so diving yeah it's like a
committing to your idea kind of thing -
exactly
doing the coke thing isn't what's cool
is that would you agree yeah for just a
little moment he got to really treat his
woman like
and that we all kind of strive for that
yeah yes there are people these odd
owners they sometimes rent out their
yachts for people to just use so that's
what happened here with Raul he and his
friends they were just they borrowed BIA
or like you know they rented the yacht
so they jumped outside of the swim
around coked out captain hit a traverse
those dudes got ripped to pieces by the
propellers dude that is the worst death
was everyone and in the [ __ ] dreamin
hello
and then the [ __ ] shark started
swimming around that's guts and we would
know that site must be all my goodness
so even the owner was arrested too or
charged in this death because of the
fact that he he knowingly let this
captain drive under the influence of
cocaine er II yeah that's crazy man he's
so cooked out he's just like let's go
and rehearse real clearly tag that is
one forward
you can't you've never done one of those
where the opposite of Oh reverse and you
go this way
oh [ __ ] like person you know he's even
looking in the rearview not sure we're
do with this thing
[Music]
I want to do it yacht party whatever I
definitely don't yeah parties seem
pretty fun though [ __ ] yeah yeah I just
got a thing in the mail of a cruise it
was like Princess cruise brochure cuz
you know how we all went walking on one
and it was like it was like a nineteen
day Cousteau Oh No thank you
that's [ __ ] long dude that cruise
sucks it sucks for a long it was like
$1500 oh that's crazy
like no wonder old people love this [ __ ]
yo ya think I should to do and it's hard
for them to be around people their age
right but then this is perfect like it's
cheap you pay fifteen hundred or
whatever and you get lost with people
your age or inclusive and it's low they
like slow
[ __ ] crews in theory is something I'd
really enjoy it but I got so sick well
you get seasick
yeah have you ever been on like
sailboats or other things like that
yeah but years before and my parents
gave me Dramamine ship who ships are
actually way more stable to some of the
other ones craziest I think I changed
because I've been on all size boats
before our last cruise but then I took
like a ten year maybe hiatus on getting
I'm never getting on a boat and then
when I got on this one I was you were
getting seasick too yeah I was never I
was never all coming here pregnant to if
I'm looking at my phone in the car
me too man that's where I guess motion
sickness but other than that I don't
know I get it from there and I'm and
then I found our cruise ships but I also
was on a Carnival cruise and that's just
always rough anyway pretty bad I would
do it again on a princess cuz my grandma
was like why the [ __ ] didn't you go on a
Princess cruise you went on a princess
it was all gram gram parents and he was
dope I liked it was the food good
no he all the heat so was I thought the
experience was cool pop I never never do
it again
really they've started finding real
restaurants in the in the ship yeah and
dolls were good and it was like [ __ ]
like 10 bucks for a four-course meal or
something like that the non free food is
actually really good what we had it was
like steak and all those other crazy
[ __ ] and then we found out Italian one
too yeah that was pretty good
carnival was like cafeteria food not
good do you guys know if there's
different levels like cuz I all I know
is princess and carnival I don't know
anything else Disney oh there's
Norwegian right it is like 15 thousand
bucks a kid what do you do after that
it's like it's like hey free drinks for
everybody on the way back you're like
what do you do
did the captain go to jail too cuz I
heard that the captain is actually
responsible for everyone's safety so
they can't even take off and leave the
port
unless there's enough life jackets for
every single person we have to do a
count and do all that stuff and is it
true that like if the ship goes down the
captain has to commit suicide and die
with the ship it's absolutely what they
don't then do all the other ship
captains look at him like you [ __ ] if
you
then he's a [ __ ] and the music has to
play the entire time as it sinking
regardless if it's a live band or any of
them knowing that fact would you still
want to be captain I'll be a [ __ ] I'll
do it until it sinks in the last minute
I'll be like [ __ ] my [ __ ] drove my
boat away yeah he probably has a life
vest underneath this clothes yeah I'm
seeing with everybody but she doesn't
want to get to [ __ ] Titanic did the
captain of the ship
[ __ ] the captain of the ship shoot
himself in the face what you'll just
explain what they did in time down with
the ship in the head or some people were
but I thought he bounced you guys know I
never watch Titanic oh my god we're not
surprised your childhoods really a long
time to see it - because I was a real
rebel kid I thought at the theater with
my cousins and when the taste came out
it was real awkward because I liked it
but they're sitting next to me that was
cool did he go with that one CDs came
out no because you should have done that
to him it only covers one eye and [ __ ]
we'll try a little hand like this by the
side of the tightness yeah he's like
yeah I remember we're sitting all the
way in the front row - just remember my
neck hurting from road to Titanic body
for four hours you know it's funny the
CG like back then it was it looked real
as [ __ ] now you watch it it's like it's
so fake as [ __ ] so dummy now should have
watched it back when it came out yeah I
think you probably would have laughed at
the same [ __ ] I did because I was
laughing when I remembered this one
scene specifically where this guy fell
and then he hit the propeller and then
he starts spinning really hard yeah yeah
I thought that was hilarious because he
had a propeller he was bidding I
probably wouldn't laugh cuz I've aha
come on have a hot date up I wouldn't
left that part I laughed at that part
and when the old people were in the room
and the room service fill in the water
and they didn't even [ __ ] get up but
I try to run or anything I laugh my ass
off position
[Music]
[Music]